[Music]
i think we're just gonna oh we're live
i can't see behind dashless you be fair
sweet sweet set of hips out the way you
guys welcome back to the break room our
daily show that keeps you updated on all
nerdy news you need to know about coming
up today we got some warner brothers
news
time to warn up brother you know what
i'm saying they're cancelled everything
because of canceling everything uh no
way home updates that movie came out
like three years ago harry styles ever
returned to the mcu please and we tell
you about our own family houses in the
house of dragon
today we're here with anna it's me i
can't finish unless he's wearing moon
shoes whoa
harry styles i love it harry styles
speaking of harry styles koi oh hey i
don't know how that relates except i
love harry styles
harry's are a welcoming community and i
appreciate them are they i love the
harry potter are they like harry styles
tick tock i've fallen so deeply into and
he's always like helping people come out
and he's like telling people's parents
and then the harry's when you
acknowledge that are always so like yeah
he's one of us so i love him in the
marvel universe we need more less toxic
did you see the guy who faked being
harry styles and was successful yes yes
shenanigans like that's what i'm worried
about with digital like media is we lean
so much into it that when the fake that
guy whole different career you guys you
hear it here first someone impersonate
eric voss we got tommy
hello
how are you excited to be here
how are you how excited scale 1-10 i'm
an 11 today guys i feel great about uh
this show i feel great about all of you
and i feel great about the pieces of
absolute trash that are watching this
show right now especially o'cragger who
sent us 10 already you fool you didn't
even know what the redemption is what if
it's we come to your house and beat you
with a bag of pennies some people would
pay extra for that one all right what if
it's we're giving him his money max it's
just pennies that's right penny's out of
time we recycled it penny pinatas anyone
that falls out while we're beating you
you get to keep all right kid dear lord
you guys for today's redemption is a
sweet sweet sweet hot one
for every one hundred dollars we get
famed author and fan fiction enthusiast
jessica r.r martin
who has offered up some snippets to her
second book neil a song of dick and
balls yeah
i got to experience it in real time so
if you guys were here before we uh for
our mandatory fun we all read you our
fan fiction whitney had one on dominic
torreiro and groot uh tommy's was
abomination in nebula
mine was darth vader and the third
sister and we're back again with neil
two a song of dick and balls now those
snippets are hot yeah and exclusive you
guys aren't gonna get that anywhere else
yeah i only hear them here and today
some say jessica r martin will never
finish a song of dick and [ __ ] i don't
think she is and we've been waiting she
just goes on and on she's in her wolf
reservoir her rolf reserve in new mexico
just
just writing about dickson balls and
songs about him so yeah if you guys want
to hear it this is your chance
to get a sneak peek you gotta but we
gotta super chat it guys unfortunately
jessica's expensive so we gotta we gotta
pay her right so right and then and the
thing about jessica are martin is she's
a great person but you know she's kind
of like she sticks to herself so these
fools here are gonna be reading it yeah
they're the ones reading the passage so
if you ever want to hear these fools
read about some dragon scales let me
tell you about it i'm
so worried up front like
everyone was coming ready never be
worried these are great but this is a
book by literature i can't wait
okay oh and now we are on to our
headlines
our lines
won't say the second part house of the
dragon was hbo's biggest original series
debut with nearly 10 million viewers
returning to westeros last sunday
evening for comparison the series finale
drew nearly 19 million all right we're
halfway there baby we're more than
halfway i was i'm actually surprised i
wasn't on i'm not on social media that
much this weekend so i didn't notice
there was a lot of people watching it
all i saw was that tick tock of someone
laughing at the apartment building and
like 18 different windows are flashing
all at the same time because it was like
right at 10 or whatever it dropped so it
was it was the opening credits and they
put the music to it and it all lined up
if you can't tell we're both heavily on
tick-tock
harry styles impersonators game of
thrones opening it's just i can't go
this hour without checking tick tock all
right we'll be okay guys we have to
we'll take a five minute break and
everybody can take their talks okay
and i ain't talking kesha uh the
directors that recently cam the
directors of the recently canceled film
batgirl tried to pull off their own
ocean's 11.
okay first off that headline is amazing
and hot director viale falla told script
a french youtube channel that he tried
to salvage some of the bad girl footage
with his phone but when he went to find
it on the server it was gone including
any footage with michael keaton the pair
also revealed that the film had almost
to no vfx completed yet so it's unlikely
a version of the film could be released
in any of its current state i want to
pause real quick michael canning
commented bill belichick is josh allen's
daddy well i i'm happy for him because
his own kids actually don't speak to him
because he's such a terrible person so
that's fine if he has a connection with
josh allen because his own daughters
hate him all right back to the headlines
okay so go pets
so
um
i'm a new england patriots fan so
oh going back up to that really quick
the fact that they tried to steal the
footage you guys we've been trying if
you can if you're listening in the chat
please go steal the footage for me yeah
um please go steal the footage release
it under a different name on tick tock
whatever you need to do i need to see
that bad girl footage what's interesting
is how often like you know we have these
moments where the the snyder cut comes
out and there's that whole thing and
they were able to finish it up and then
deadpool gets leaked right that seems
like the combination of the deadpool
snyder cut i just need an intern to go
in there and just kind of seems like
it's deep in a vault though if it's not
on the servers like where is it is it on
like a single flash drive like toy story
2 with that person accident delete it
they had to save the day you guys ever
know that pastor two got entirely
deleted oh yes i heard that one editor
one person had it no here's what i think
this is interesting because when when we
first heard the story sorry i screwed up
the prompter uh when we first heard the
story about batgirl they were like it's
99
done now we're hearing that it's maybe
more like
60 percent done which makes it a little
i mean it's still bad that they canceled
it in my opinion i i think they should
have you know reworked it and found a
way to at least put it on hbo max but
definitely the panic of the initial
announcement was like this movie's
finished well and it's like coming out
tomorrow no it's not what part of
department do you mean finish post or
like production because they didn't even
finish the
vfx there
also zack snyder stole his footage back
so we'll go in there and steal their
footage also can we acknowledge the fact
that that's not really fair for mackerel
that people are like it's not very good
if they didn't even finish the visual
effects like it's like who's watching
the movie that's got like the grey
blonde yeah
like in the test screen did they just go
all right now here right there will be
fire coming out it's like frasier
walking around and people are writing
like and fire fire fire smoke fire
fire it's not fair to the movie if
there's the testosterone that's true i
know they have to start there but if
that's our context that ain't right i
agree i agree i agree um we have new
info on the spiderman no way home
re-release in theaters the more fun
stuff edition will have 11 minutes of
new footage it's coming to theater
september 2nd tickets went on sale today
well if there's no bony horse i'm out
i don't know if they're going to put the
bony horse in release the bony horse cut
i don't think anybody wants a bony horse
good everybody in the chat does look
good guys give me a bone horse if you
want a bony horse pony horse army stand
up
let me hear you oh boy they're loud and
they're proud and they're getting
automatically deleted
they can't silence you i see you all
rudolph
don't be i'm gonna oh man i was trying
to get their fast food off this are you
guys are you guys gonna go back for more
fun stuff in theaters
i am back i'm gonna see it again
absolutely i'm gonna take my nephews i
think like this one of the only movies i
would see a re-release of this close to
release like it's only been a year tell
me what the more fun stuff part is
because like alex reese i'm like 11
minutes
i mean that's half a tv show which tv
show yeah
cause i'm watching the one hour
uh cheers uh something from the 2000's
uh
2000's pre-commercial break did you say
freshers
grinch brooklyn nine-nine
rick and morty steven's choice okay give
me sophie's choice no movie harry styles
was asked by rolling stone about
stop it with their bony horse push rain
berries
oh it's a unicorn yeah hell yeah unicorn
bones i love that i'll let that one
slide i love to eat unicorns harry
styles was asked by rolling stone about
his future in the mcu and his answer
sounded like he wanted things to stay
the same as it was oh
well it must have been all that late
night talking
that was music for sushi restaurants my
ears oh my god i'm gonna hit you he said
about that watermelon sugar keep talking
keep talking see where i get you he said
he
said he said he doesn't imagine he'd do
a movie for a while and said he thinks
there will be only time
his formatting's fine his formatting's
horrible he thinks there'll be a time
again when he'll cut he'll crave it but
that he's currently focused on his music
career perverted answer
i think there may be a time i'll cry of
acting again
but until then my belly's full with
music you have to read all of these
fanfictions that harry styles voices
voice sometimes when i'm putting on my
thigh-high boots i crave an acting
career
i think he's so perfect for the role
that i really hope he's important soon
like i i can see where this might be a
thing not so eternal 2 or whatever but
like he as eros is so like that
character's so bowie-esque and he is as
well like there's that like rampant
sexuality and fluidity and i think the
the mcu could use some [ __ ] i think
freaking could use some freaking
everything
i just read that as i said and it really
threw me off captain america virgin
oh my god well didn't they already are
they already starting uh didn't he
uh pat and oswald say that they already
got started working yeah that weird day
of five weeks of like yeah of everyone
just leaks oh that was the day that uh
what's her name rosaria dawson was like
oh my bad uh you guys now oscar isaac's
in the desert like hey yeah he said
he said i'm on a boat why wouldn't we
make moon knight too or will we or why
we won't just we're doing that you guys
want college humor to come back uh we
got a new look at a new suit for iron
heart let's take a look real quick
i don't like that john said
maybe not
uh so yeah these are the toy leaks right
oh i guess we should can we should we
put spoilers up
no no okay i think it's fine uh up the
banner top okay the banner's up after uh
we showed the image now
go back in time our commentary is
spoiler that's right so that is uh the
iron heart suit look at how cool it is
it looks really sick i like it it's
pretty
um
so
let's
we we've seen how many suits now we've
seen like three we've seen three now
total including this one
let's theorize these suits which will
come first in what order so do we think
we're gonna get the one in black panther
first because that's because we already
we talked about it once it was like
these are maybe seven different
prototypes yeah which one in order the
from what we've seen i see it even as
like the ambassador chip we're talking
about with wakanda to mit she might have
been building one at mit and maybe
that's part of the conversation like
maybe she was inspired by iron man is
building a suit for like a class and
then wakanda's like hey we got some tech
for you and then one another like
there's a prototype that's wakandan like
we start with her because i want her to
be able to be independent right like we
want her to have done something that was
like this is why wakanda reached out
yeah and then maybe a second suit is
wakanda and then we get the hero suit
100 so and then the hero suit can evolve
i mean if iron man gets like 10 suits a
movie yeah do you think that red one is
going to be the hero it sucks because
that red costume for the toy is the only
full outfit we've seen right so
i guess we saw the the photos yeah we
saw the big ones the big mac one i
definitely think is the suit in the cave
like the one she's built yourself it's
got that energy to it
it's got it's got suit in a cave
energy's got
why is she building that suit in a cave
well she wants to look like what's that
video game character that's awesome
she's a big fan of
a uh of people's pointing out that that
that uh toy league picture does look a
little bit power ranger-ish and i would
be
reticent to disagree
i think
toy leaks are hard to judge yeah i'm not
mad about it i like power rangers she
looks cool i just you know i think the
the final suit mirrors the comic books
the most so i assume that's the one that
she's going to like bob around in like
on purpose the red suit yeah the red
suit has the most comic book parallel
the uh the legs are are pretty girthy
though so i don't know if that's gonna
be like a flying thing or if that's
gonna be like how cause they they they
flare out kind of mech-ishly it's hard
to tell in that picture that's only not
the legs it's also nerve-wracking
because can you put that photo one more
time it has the photo of the toy and it
says wakanda forever can you leave the
photo up for the remainder of the
episode as the only thing that we show
and then we'll be making faces at the
audience for the rest of the time i like
it
i don't think that suit shows up in
wakanda forever you then why the hell is
it being trademarked as one kind of
forever
not not me cursing you out there
why would we all say something let's
talk about stuff like that
you guys go ahead and send us some more
super chat so i can make koi read the
stuff
that jessica r martinez going on with
we're only a quarter of the way there
but jessica wrote
jessica martin spent a lot of time on
these
okay
do you think maybe she gets fully formed
and then her show spins off directly
from that then i think
i assumed it would have been an origin
of of some kind
well i think the show might do that yeah
i might do that a little bit i don't
know i like what i like with she-hulk is
them being like let's just do this
really quick and then we'll go back so
maybe it is like a very brief stint or
very quicker stand i think they know
that people's attention spans have grown
shorter since like the two thousand
styles tick tocks yeah yeah
there you go you need 30 seconds 30
seconds or less um what i do think is
going to happen is that we're going to
be seeing her in wakanda forever making
different prototype suits yes but i
think that red one will be the finisher
that it leaves from wakanda to her own
series oh so you when i see the same
just one step sooner for you yeah i
think so i also i'm like i'm still can
you show me the one the k suit
give me caves give me caves oh wow i
need to know why she's in the cave i
can't get over why she's in the cave
working unless she's like really trying
to imitate uh tony stark but
and do you think she's trapped
well isn't there the cave in wakanda
where they were like kind of working
there whether
we saw the the
the vibranium mine yeah maybe she's just
in a part of the mine i would either
maybe instead of iron it's vibranium
suit
maybe vibe heart
vibe change it change the wooden heart
um so what do we think i heard surviving
with all of you today but not the chat
not the viewers you'll never have my
heart right okay so nina did say isn't
that sure he's like thank you sorry i
was reading this out thanks for the
horrified silences
i love the yes ending going on with the
crew today okay go ahead i was reading
the chat because they're saying he's
right yeah you don't know for sure it
doesn't make me feel like a psycho at
all when you all sit in stoic silence
that's right i just wanted for you
it felt right yeah like i did it
fun not cheering
that's great
we wouldn't have happened
every time i imagine sherry working i
imagine her at the like actual station
that was indoors not a cave sure
i pictured her at mit like developing
something and the cave is very
interestingly direct like you know i can
only work well in tony stark's
environment they're like you gotta yeah
it's like i need the the fear always so
i can quickly bitten by a radioactive
cave and now i'm iron man
i'm iron stone man can't work without
bad cave lighting damn it oh my god the
slow drip of water is my background
noise
shut up john
can you show it
because this and the samus drawing looks
similar like maybe she starts with the
one that's kind of piecemail that has
like pieces on like different areas and
then it evolves into this because if you
look at that like hand cannon to me it
looks like that turns into beast boy
like that big boy
you think we're starting so you're
starting with the cave one to the gun
open yeah exactly then to red although
does that last one not remind you of
cyborg keep going i'm so sorry no no no
that's fine but maybe the reason that
that suit is big is because there's a
big opponent that she needs to fight
perhaps a hulk perhaps a
different type of hulk perhaps a world
war of hulks you know maybe that's like
her hulkbuster
i don't know that is true she could be
using that fursuit or the bigger suit to
fight in wakanda and it just it sucks
because that's on set of iron art isn't
it that big suit right that's why i
think they're going to do that as the
show is an origin story yeah because i
can't imagine they'd have like uh also
the young avengers you want to get to
know her while she's young like you want
to see the college stuff i imagine
that's true well is the show so if she's
going to show up in wakanda forever
first then the show is going to go back
and talk about what she did before then
because this is the show coming out in
phase six i'm not trying to poke holes
no no i think you're right i just think
that the timeline is interesting like
does she have it developed with wakandan
tech first and then maybe she does her
own thing maybe maybe they take away the
wakandan tech like she's not worthy she
has to build a room okay that's true i
think this is what i this is my kind of
just standalone theory i'm on an island
here i understand i think by the time
iron heart comes out we are going to be
in the midst of a kind of sub saga in
phase six that is world war hulk it
feels like we're all heading there with
the she-hulk show with uh the sikarians
trying to deliver a message to
to uh uh mark ruffalo's hulk main you
know the original hulk i feel like
ironheart will tie into that that series
will have implications every series will
have some implication into pushing the
world war hulk saga that will probably
ultimately lead us to that uh kang
dynasty secret wars uh final avengers
movie i'm thinking they might do maestro
through the whole hulk and then have old
[ __ ] team up with doctor doom because
they remember they were like so maybe
that leads to the kang dynasty by way of
time travel and we get world war hulk
leading to maestro my my show versus
that's not even fair
he's kind of like a doom level yeah
that's a poor girl she's just starting
out uh how close uh and i'm talking
mainly to you koi at this point how
close are we to the comics so far from
what we know about riri williams
she doesn't have a direct uh parallel to
wakanda in the comics like they're doing
here but i do think the mit thing is
going to be basically she's a a smart
student that's exceptional that gets
recruited by
like wasp and this really badass team of
scientists i could see that instead of
being that group be wakandans so i think
they're going to kind of plug and play
like her being recruited to do her own
thing from being this this group to
being a wakandan group so it's kind of
plug and play if they do it right could
you see uh what we had and what if we're
peppa peppa we're pepper sorry okay
i think we're just talking about
salt and pepper pots um do you know if
pepper pot the soylent pepper pots and
sherry were together working together
and using stark industry stuff do you
think you could see that with riri and
pepper in the future what i'd be curious
about is if they ever do anything that's
like a nod to tony stark's ai if they go
that yeah i think if you bring in pepper
you almost have to bring in the there's
an entire plot where the voice in her
head isn't jarvis it's tony so if you
have pepper everyone that reads the
comments can be like yeah they don't
it's gonna feel kinda well i mean i i'm
just mainly thinking of where riri's
story can lead to because it's like her
suit is very powerful yes but if i have
her going against old hulk right right
yeah not really set up well yeah it's
not said i see you're fighting more like
tech based villains yeah exactly
especially since she's a young avenger
that deals with like building her own
tech and i think that each of the young
avengers are kind of going to mirror
their their legacy character counterpart
so i think she'll be fighting more like
you know techie do we have any um
young techs right now really uh bruno
oh yeah bruno oh yeah bruno yeah oh well
he's going to ucla right but that could
lead to wakandan like you
yeah they might have a bunch of other
schools that they're uh working with for
the next the minds of tomorrow uh
speaking of the minds of tomorrow yeah
it's important to nurture the mind and
in order to nurture the mind you got to
get good sleep and that's why we want to
thank helix sleep for sponsoring the
break room this week
a good night's sleep is so important and
nothing helps you achieve the perfect
night's sleep like the right mattress
that's why we want to thank our friends
at helix sleep i thank them every night
when i sleep on my helix mattress hill
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else like i said i mean if you
have kids you should probably buy them
mattresses my kids personally sleep on a
concrete floor until they learn with
helix you'll get again the silence is
great guys thank you with lyrics you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
they have several different mattresses
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains and even that's this the copy okay
now at a certain point it gets just a
little confusing and a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers i love
my helix mattress as i've said i've had
it for years i sleep like an angel just
ask anyone uh just take the quiz and
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door ship for free you don't ever need
to go to the mattress store again just
go to heal
helix sleep dot
slash break room take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life now
here's what's even better they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will love it or else helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans so great night sleep is
never far away helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress sale orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
break room all right
emerson has it right we aren't being
silent we're listening sure of course
absolutely i believe that now
before we go into our second ad i think
we'll take a little break and i'll read
jessica r martin's fan fiction so i'm
just jessica r martin's uh publicist of
course and so she gave me a little
snippets of her books um these are very
rough okay draft ones
[Music]
but i do have some time i'm thirsty
okay okay okay okay i'm good
anna i swear to god we have um so we
have some titles for you to choose from
oh great we have drakaras bound by
scales okay um a love story for daenerys
dragons
wriggle and drogon okay two girls know
jamie a love story of brienne of tarth
and cersei lannister wow
uh i
i'm your daddy now a love story by damon
targaryen and alice at hightower okay
one night only a love story of sir
kristen cole oh
um and a love story of oberyn martel
pedro pascal's character i'm sorry
and daenerys targaryen she said this
one's kind of weak so if you want to
read the others okay then i'll
uh well all of those sound incredible i
would like to hear all five i hope we
raised that much money i'm gonna do one
night only if you don't mind
yes one minute
one night only a love story of sir
christian cole
you've been invited to the jousting
tournament to celebrate the coming oh
god of the king's air but you're late
you walk a little faster but not too
fast to draw attention to yourself
you're speed walking through a tunnel to
the entrance and there's not an open
seat in sight
ah you sigh to yourself
you should have come sooner
you turn to face a christian coal
he looks around to make sure no one's in
sight and pushes you against the stoned
wall
i've missed you i've been waiting to see
you
don't break my heart again
he ungloves his hand and touches your
face ouch
not here kristen you whisper
i spend every night
every waking moment thinking about you
missing your voice
especially at night
you don't think about me us
how perfect you looked all spread out
for me
kristen
you yelled embarrassed
what he laughs i've kept a secret but
it's starting to devour me baby
i want them to know about us not just
some dornish boy
he spins you around so you're facing the
wall
the echoes of people cheering are
bellowing through the tunnel
he kisses your neck
and even if someone was looking you
wouldn't care at this point
shhh i've got you baby
do you want me to continue you nod your
head aggressively out my neck pushing
back against him to feel his length
words baby i need you to answer me yes
you scream
this is serious
[ __ ] perfect he rasps
the egg
[Applause]
wow
that was spicy i didn't expect it to be
so like serious like jessica
martin does not play did you watch our
episode
we
paid top dollar for jessica r martin and
she has so far delivered wow
no more money let's raise a few more
bucks
to hear about a few more [ __ ]
now
we want to thank our friends at better
help
because god knows after reading means
we're going to need to talk to someone
we also want to share uh just a quick
word from our sponsor like i said better
help keeping your mind happy and healthy
is important so why not invest some time
money and energy doing just that i've
told you all i'm a better help boy all
right i'm part of the better help army i
had my appointment this morning cleared
some
major space out in my head sometimes you
gotta cry it out sometimes you just
gotta scream it out either way better
help can help you it's online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat only therapy sessions and because
it's online you can do it from wherever
you feel most comfortable for me that's
my computer desk with a chair that i
bought on let go from a man whose family
had died they even have the option to
have the camera turned off so they don't
have to see anyone on camera not all of
them just the ones that have the leather
chairs jesus christ so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to plus it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy in person who wants to
do that my god unless there's a little
caesars next door detroit's finest pizza
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com break room
that's better h-e-l-p-com
slash break room all right
i i want to preface first uh on behalf
of jessica r martin yeah that was the
longest one in the batch okay the rest
are much shorter all right um would be
fine if they were even longer you're
perfect i just don't want to scare away
the two of the other folks in the chat
and the other folks in the chat some of
you guys are wilding out we are
42 away from another erotic moment
but uh
now
i think we should go to the most erotic
segment on the show it's time for
mandatory five
[Applause]
yes
the segment
so full of life
that we hit the graphic twice hit it
again
yes
the segment that tears us apart so we
play the toy league of ironheart hit the
toy league
john is gone
i'm going quicker at that like yeah
the segment that happens over and over
again so play the thirsty thespian
graphic hit it again
that's right
now mandatory fun
john
the cackling i look good
from the other side
now
uh
what was i saying mandatory fun is when
i gather my three best friends in the
whole world
together to have a little bit of
non-optional fun with me and let's face
facts house of the dragon gave us a
deeper insight into the targaryen family
and uh you know some people last in that
family longer than others so now
i want to know more about your guys's
families your crest your motto your
family's physical traits now
unfortunately
i can't be here for mandatory fun
i have an appointment with dr nasty
i'm getting lemur kidneys put in
uh unfortunately i my kidneys were
described as destroyed by dr nasty he
simply said my where there once were
kidneys were now only uh prunes a
prune-like substance uh basically
liquefied so he's gonna put some lemur
kidneys in i can't and uh i'll i uh i
did find someone to co-host okay so uh
or did you mention michael beck told i
will lose my [ __ ]
he'll be around leave this place right
now maybe it's just our martin you never
know all right honestly she was supposed
to show up instead she's in her new
mexico home
writing more and not giving it to people
is she gonna does she accept notes on
her work yeah she does i told you she'll
take notes i'll write her a letter after
this
without the effects the work has had on
me
anna sorry
i need water all right oh
oh who's this good day everyone i wish
you would leave whoever it is i wish it
would go always an accident my name
is tamaya finn beck told first of his
name
lord of the realm
king of the nasty boys
keeper
of the enchanted treasure
and patron saint of that booty
now koi's great
such a child let me reveal
my family crest oh for we vectors are
known for two things
my tripophobia chocolate chip cookies
and making bad bats with bookies what so
we have bet slips and cookies on our
crest
and of course our family slogan beat the
bookie take the cookie
i like it
beat the bookie take the cookie beat the
bookie take the cookie cookie a metaphor
no the cookie is my mother's delicious
chocolate chip cookies also not a
metaphor
now
each of you are drawing your own
let me tell you a little more about my
land we own a
we own a bit of land and have a castle
in a place simply known as the crack
[Laughter]
it's two giant mounds of natural earth
with a little crevice in the center
where we have our castle simply known as
the plug what's the smell like the plug
sits between the crack
and the natural flowing water of river
keeps the crack fresh to death
i swear to god hopefully by now one of
you is almost done
drawing because i'm almost done sharing
things about the bechtold family
our natural enemy is the pussycat
i can't follow that
okay i got it all right anna please
introduce your family
uh
the the vanstens are uh oh god we are
the
house of raccoons
as you can see
we hide in the bechtel's trash cans
safety and food so
it's a natural you know evolvement yes
to keep safe and well fed and sometimes
we do spooky little pranks we
better
have kindly welcomed the vanstones to
finger around our crack for years
it's a bad it's a bad scene it's a bad
it's how we keep them well it's a
fragile alliance as the crack is
sensitive
we're thinking of moving but
they won't let us
catch us
saw the cliffs can't wait all right on
to the house of clements
just a peach there's nothing wrong with
that
[Music]
this is the clemens
vigil
yeah oh procedural that's right sigil
star citizen yes yes
and um
um
we carry a lot behind us
we carry a lot behind us but we never
look back
we never look back
and uh we have uh we've been known to
drop it once or twice
known to bust it back and bust it down
and bust it out so i drew this for my
family's crest it's heavy hefty but
always can carry in two hands that's
right and of course the clemens
were known for their backs
until the backs were blown out one day
and now they
dazzle they keep their armor
booty heavy
they keep the armor fully over the ass
and the rest of the body is
their exposed is
keep the peach within reach
they are the natural enemy of the
battles
because when the mounds are too thick
the crack is out of reach
crash
have been known to try and get into the
clemence's round mounts
they don't like it though
yeah they swat us away
but always come back to the comfortable
home of the bechtold's crack
coy go ahead i think i did way too much
oh my god i read all that and i was like
i'm gonna do all of this all right he's
the wicked gendrous of the northeast
and uh our family motto is carpe awesome
we choose to seize the awesome yeah and
we have a dual animal because some
families they do one animal but no no
we're about duality and we're about
seasonally awesome so we are both monkey
and komodo dragon that is
oh my dude it may also be snake
genitalia who knows
what's possible
with the monkey komodo dragon
jondros the noble gentros whose fortress
sits atop the bulge
a long veiny region
you heard me rich with tributaries
rivers
and reservoirs
will you also read the polls for us
before tommy comes back yes
have you seen house of dragon episode 1
yet no
no
do you think batgirl will be leaked or
is it gone forever gone forever
do you plan on seeing more fun stuff
version of no way home in theaters no
wow y'all are negative yeah what's going
on
they want none of this
now
do you think we'll see harry styles
slash eros and phase five yes oh
when it comes to harry we're willing to
be positive but when it comes to
spider-man and house of dragons we're
little negative nancies we'll fire upon
you i bite my thumb at now
oh no
that's it for mandatory fun now vote on
us and read some horny things i just saw
that you don't have to if you don't want
to we can always make koi do it oh no
the people voted i don't think that's
there so we have
bound by scales and this is that
involves a dragon it's just two dragons
it's just two dragons let's do it baby
okay
all right
uh what
your character
welcome to horny town with dragons now
with more dragons okay
these aren't your average fairy tale
dragons these targaryen dragons were
bred to fight
and breed they shout that doesn't
and breathe they shall again i see i
gotcha
regal is strong fiery his skin was
yellowish green and projected in the
moonlight what does that mean
dragon drug drug
drogon was strong his limbs were long
and robust much like koi's emblem that's
actually a pretty good visual
representation wow uh he was a
powerhouse
dottie yes i think that means strong and
protruding oh sick strong and protruding
but even underneath all those scales
were two creatures with a lust for
family that sounds sweet actually
nice
i hope jessica r martin's not watching
because she does not like feedback you
know i only have a fourth grade reading
level yes r martin curiosity would be
fighting at these dragons tonight drogon
playfully nipped at rhaegal's wing
encouraging regal to swing his neck back
back both slamming into each other
that's this sounds like intercourse to
me
drogon's wings encapsulates
before he's knocked down
oh it's getting it's getting violent
regal uses his strong legs and kicks
onto the ground
be careful regal swiftly scurries on top
and pins down drogoons wings in the wet
soil what's it wet with we'll never know
it's obviously dragon not author
stop it as the adrenaline drifts away
drogon feels a heaviness on his abdomen
a burden to be released no pressure that
heavy he's ever felt before they both
look into each other's piercing slitted
dragon eyes that was a hard one to read
drogon's chest is rising with
anticipation and fear knowing he must
fully submit and be at the mercy his
brother his brother they're targaryen
dragons targaryens have sex with each
other why are you bad at jessica she's
just the puppet i'm just a publicist
why are people so into incest porn can
someone answer me now okay all right
it's forbidden
it's forbidden regal snarls and leans
down on to drogon's long neck his
dagger-sized teeth piercing drogon
scales ouch and the loud roar is heard
across
slavers bay
less graphic than i thought yeah i'm not
bad i'm not bad or mad at that okay
well guys we have lots more
we have lots more so you know you know
what to do hit that super chat let's
read some of these super chats uh we've
got wolverine said give me some more
nasty nasty nasties wolverine i agree
great names
13 says let's hear more jessica martin
we heard a little more no it did not
disappoint oh gregory we already read
yours but we appreciate you coming in
hot ryan presley i'm about to go
bartending and talk marvel with my
customers whether they like it or not
also calling them trash bags with love i
i urge you to do that with caution but i
appreciate it yeah and write some fanfic
while you're at it and send it to us
yeah oh and we have to thank you tisha
neticia natasha
tanisha tanisha sorry naticia naticia is
a girl i did stand-up comedy class with
like 15 years ago tanisha who always
comes in hot with it with a super chat
putting us over the edge we appreciate
you
td jones since tony is gone i think riri
is going to be a scroll oh boy
okay i'm watching watching the first
episode of she-hulk i immediately was
like okay so who's the scroll right
who's the squirrel i think it's nikki
justin quinn said there is too much cool
on one side of the table which side oh i
like how it's kind of nagging because we
have to go like who's the better one the
audience it's gotta be the girls we all
know it's the girls there's trash bags
respectively asks to mix it up
uh and then whoa boy i
gonna try and say this name right tribe
say dk
what do you think riri's role will be in
secret wars and other phases of the mcu
i mean i think she's gonna basically be
the the new tech wizard right she's
going to be the new tech superhero the
exquisite but you know like the the
superhero that's powered up by their own
inventions rather than uh i think yeah
also like i'm not mirroring what
happened end game but what i did like in
endgame was like literally pepper and
iron man flying through beating
everyone's ass with their
suits so i would love to see re-redoing
that to anybody on uh in secret wars i'd
also love to see her and shuri like team
up yeah i love i love technology fights
yeah tech fights more than i like people
because people were shipping like peter
and shuri and i think it'd be
interesting to see like riri and shuri
having some sort of like sister like you
know that kind of like
i love it and then bring them all in
just for fun
what's better tech fights or magic
fights
i like tech because it's just like it uh
it ends at one point it can't go too far
like you can still beat the crap out of
tony and he has to submit whereas in
magic you can keep going it's really
hard to actually
dr doom's awesome because he's boats
all right dr strange had a baby
richard's ego i want to report
that jessica was voted best house crest
i don't think it was even close
not
chip cookies and available slips
although
in the crack
i'm told uh people uh quite like the
chocolate chip cookies and gambling so
you know what as long as the crack is
happy
too much chocolate clean it up as long
as my butt is popular also when you said
nikki's the squirrel i keep
like i was like when i saw nicki i was
like i think she's going to be in agatha
house of uh the covenant i think she's a
witch i think she's a witch and we'll
talk about it later i think if you like
that witchy bob it's good i will we can
talk about it later but i think it is
we'll
watch inside marbles you guys would love
it this is the first it's too
distracting
nothing's more distracting than these
sweet sweet reads and we are 780 dollars
i can't come on 80 more bucks so we can
read another one and we can make koi do
it this year yes
also the jackie's being like why is koi
scowling at the camera i have resting
boston face
that's what i'm doing when i'm not
actively engaging and i'll go ahead and
say this if we get to 400 dollars i know
that's a lot that's a huge one we'll
read them all we'll read them all for
400. you get them all i will read the
whole collection
you don't have to read no i'm joking
jessica who knows the author personally
will read one but uh we can't do it for
less than 400 look at that we're out of
rundown creator what happened yeah i can
do it too if you need help oh my
goodness
i need an adult technology is shut john
l that's talking dragons
i know how to do it john you can stay
there stay there john this one uh yeah
yeah i do i do
uh
we're live tech difficulties people that
ask if this is live this is is live
do do do you guys i hope you're having a
good time
uh and well they had a good time
throwing peaches in the chat that's for
sure
you guys we uh have a little bit for
matt reeves that i think is actually
astounding news i agree that is a bit of
news
this is honestly very positive but also
i'm very
confused by it
you did your second ad right yeah okay
sorry i was just wondering matt reeves
oh
you were sitting right next to me before
matt how man you got
why are you so mad at me you're supposed
to pay attention to the show i
we talk about butts and we get along and
i love you jessica matt reeves signs an
overall deal with the warner brothers
you guys uh they said someone like matt
will buy for him whatever he wants to do
we're making an investment for whatever
matt feels a pull uh feels a pull toward
in the batman universe and otherwise he
had an open invitation to go wherever
his interest interest takes him will
lean into whatever matt wants to do in
terms of the writer directors out there
working in this very elevated genre
space with everything matt's done from
let the right one in
let the right one in to the apes trilogy
to the batman he's in a class by himself
which is true i love let the right one
uh but anyways
that that's the bigger news than what's
expected especially with warner brothers
everything that's been going on
everything they're doing to cartoon
network so
is is he going to just patrol the batman
is he going to be bringing in all the
new batman characters are we just saying
goodbye to batfleck now i mean it sounds
to me like they're going to be building
a separate universe shared and like i
did a whole video over earlier
uh where it's like basically doing
really well
you're lucky i love real quick
but basically positing we should do a
matt reeves universe that's kind of akin
to dc's black label where it allows
itself to be continuity free and maybe
darker and maybe more creative freedom
for the directors like you get your
directors that want to play like todd
phillips but not be beholden to a
universe and then you make your shared
universe separate my problem with that
or not my problem with it is more so do
you think it's profitable for the
originals of the original series or the
original the one that's currently going
yeah i don't know if they care about
that i don't think they do and that's
what we're going to use
by just doing this instead of the flash
point like i don't it seems to me
they're fighting to keep flash coming
out so it's like everything else they
don't have as much investment i mean it
must flash must be good right
it must be really good for them to be
like we're gonna let
uh
whatever's happening that we don't
really talk about in the show happen
and then we're still gonna put it out
but it's also comic appropriate to have
something like a flashpoint event that
can restart everything that's why i
bring up flashpoint is it's it's a
multiverse shifting event so it would
allow for i don't think matt reeves
batman should ever interact with anyone
else like that should be its own corner
i had one i want batman and i think
that's what they're doing here they're
letting matt reeves go like make genre
stuff make cool things wasn't their goal
uh sort of to set up a a multi-verse in
a
timeline like marvel so why would
bringing in a new batman that doesn't
interact with anyone really be good for
that plan of making a long-term sort of
thing i mean i think that the only way
to allow directors to have the creative
freedom is by having two universes
basically and i think that's the
strength of doing not what marvel's
doing i think they should do what
marvel's doing and the opposite because
if you're always waiting for an easter
egg or a tie-in that's not a movie
that's a commercial so like i think you
can do both in this restart and i think
that's what matt reeves basically just
got is like a multi-year deal with all
that stuff with all these shows being
cancelled though like how much budget is
being filtered into to this new exactly
with the profit right like batman was
originally budgeted at 100 million with
covid it ballooned to 200 million but it
still made like 7.35 yeah so that's one
of those rare movies that exceeded
expectations both with the inflated
budget and whatnot so if he's able to to
triple money then you're gonna want to
invest in that guy do you think we're
gonna
we should anticipate like the joker and
this crossing pass eventually well the
joker has the continuity where bruce
wayne's like seven exactly and like i
hope not because to me the beauty
beautiful thing about todd phillips
joker is that it's inherently meant to
be a commentary in the archetypal
characters it's not meant to be a joker
it's meant to be a commentary on what
that is so like the way that lands is is
negating that whole thing so i'm
thinking what they're gonna do with the
harley quinn movie is like you know the
musical elements are gonna be in his
head and psychosis and i don't even know
if they're gonna have an actual love
story if it's gonna be him in you know
psychiatric going imagining their love
story like it might not follow comics
and that might be a more special thing
than having
whereas you know the batman is not
beholden to comic books but it's at
least on a comic path 100 i agree with
that and i would want that more than the
other one just because i feel like uh i
don't have any ill will tour matt reeves
i don't think he doesn't know comics but
i just think if you're gonna go in this
direction we've seen the batman origin
so many damn times and we've seen every
kind of version of batman just recycled
even from the comics to like media just
do your own thing do it and he did so i
think so well i i personally love the
batman because it's not there were zero
pearls yes and i like that about it i'd
like to carry forward without martha's
or pearls
and like where we left off with the
batman so interesting you can do a mr
freeze you can do a year zero you can do
the flooded world you can do penguin
show which apparently is still going on
that was part of this too yeah colin
farrell penguin's part of this whole
situation so you can do a crime saga and
then you can introduce all of these
characters through an arkham type of
situation and grow out your gotham but
keep it separate
i feel that i like it let's uh i want to
answer before we get too close to the
end i want to answer some of the
questions i've already been brought up
in the chat but also you guys let us
know if you want if you think because
our last question here was do they do we
think that matt reeves will be working
on different dc properties do you think
this will just give like uh
open the door for him to just do what
they wanted uh james gunn to do
basically they wanted him to be the
kevin feige of the dc do you think now
they're just going to let him do
whatever he wants he's like i want to do
a suicide squad mavericks plastic man oh
my god if they just did like matt reeves
like gets to do a new season of doom
patrol i'd be like
but how much fun would it be to do like
the daniels get plastic man like i want
separate corner you know audible i want
a separate corner universe where you
don't have the directors beholden to
continuity that's true that's true i
feel like and i don't i think you can
just go off at this point i'll see what
sticks warner brothers because you're
just getting rid of everything i love um
okay so what do we got here
chat pics dc character they would like
to see matt reeves take on uh the green
lantern i would love anyone to do the
green lantern again space cops i wanted
that you don't want it oh i want it i
just wanted to be done right because
they've not made a space like
uh would you see superhero would you
like to see matt reeves take on other oh
okay
these are the others uh luke simmons
constantine would be cool but i think
you should introduce other characters
that are more notable first uh does
anyone know constantine i mean i guess
it's kind of to our world known but i
don't know if he's you know like people
that don't read comics he's fairly niche
okay
okay that makes sense uh what's the vibe
said teen titans
could you imagine a dark teen titans
robin oh my god
i want teen titans when uh robin is
like the villain they did an episode
like that in the original teen titans
run where he was so obsessed with the
villain that he kept seeing him
everywhere and everyone was like dude
he's not here and they had to like hold
him down and fight him and they realized
robin has just gone off the deep end
he's going mad i would love matt reeves
to do it um martian manhunter didn't we
get a wait no we're going to get martian
manhunter didn't he he's in the snyder
cut yeah yeah yeah yeah he's in the
snyder cut at like the end he goes to uh
does he go to like bruce wayne's like
little like cottage thing yeah there's a
little pow wow he like floats down yeah
they have a little barbecue they got so
close
um i we are we're getting a red hood
we're getting the red hood
i think so uh i and i think that what
we'll get with red hood is comic book
accurate and and i do want to say like
what i was saying about the mcu is a
benefit to the mcu but not to the dcu if
you're starting over i like the easter
egg thing works if you start from
scratch now but i think if we start
looking for things like the snyder cut
like the martian manhunter that's where
it gets to be a problem so like red
hood's gonna be exciting because they're
probably gonna tie it to kingpin they're
probably gonna tie into things we've
we've been invested in because the mcu
has a 15-year like investment so give us
those easter eggs but i think starting
dc expecting those isn't healthy
perfect uh does anyone i'm just looking
at the chat now someone said does anyone
like the time series and i think uh not
to
boo i think i might be the only person
also if you do in the chat please hit me
up because
uh no the series
i like teen titans i love teen titans i
love both versions of the teen titans
and the movie uh movie was phenomenal
um what else we have fragrant my fave
hot d which is
also the dragon character it's a tie
between
corliss oh is that uh and damien why
coral is fray girl koi komoda dragons
are one of my two favorite animals uh
commodore moto crew photo criminal
dragon is my favorite stand up
there i love that their bacteria was so
disgusting in their mouth that we
thought it was acid and poisonous but
it's just because it's so they're just
you know they have a kind of third eye
on the top of their head they can see
shadows i love them they're so cool yeah
it's not like a full eye but they can
see they can detect shadows too but it's
like this on top of your head what about
now
this is a weird episode of koi's comic
corner this every time koi's on is a
weird episode period guys period last
time i was talking about butts you guys
we didn't really make it to the 300 so
koi will not be reading
fan fiction maybe i can make him do it
on a tick tock just venmo me you know
i'll take some snapshots of it all right
hit my vendors
i'll send someone i'll leak jessica's
fanfic
don't forget we're still doing our clip
of the week so make sure you submit your
favorite br clips in our discord do
exclamation point clips for more info
reminder leave us those voicemails huh
we might be doing some voicemails here
if they're good enough if you leave me a
voicemail breathing heavy again i'm
gonna leave it in my personal collection
but i'm not going to read it on the air
or play it on the air so what do you say
guys time to get out of here let's do it
gang let's get that lemur
to the crack
to the crack